akö nem fojnak össze minden külön
sterilen elválasztva egyegy dobozba van
és amikor egyedül van akkor szépen kezdi
kinyitja a doboz rendet rak arrébb teszi
veszi a következőt és valahogy egy ilyen
csapszerelés számára egy doboz amit meg
kell csinálni és ha mondjuk
lenne konfliktusunk a háttérbe akkor nem
kapcsolná össze a kettőt hogy talán
azért reagálok hirtelen vagy ha
valamilyen személyes problémám van akkor
talán az ért reagál tehát ő konkrétan
most csapat szerel tehát ezért van az
hogyha ki van téve egy tál kimosott vagy
szennyes ruha és be kell tenni a
mosógépbe és mondjuk az út közepére van
kitéve akkor a férfi ezt úgy értelmezi
hogy ez egy akadály amit át kell lépni
szóval eszébe se jut hogy ezt meg kéne
fogni és be kéne tenni a mosógépbe és
elindítani erre van az a történet hogy
már gungor mondta hogy egy ő odöt hozá
és mondta hyyám a férfiak nem látják a
szennyeseket
[Zene]